hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar a novel approach for single cell
multi omec analysis to identify
regulatory signatures encounter i am
michelle ashton of lab roots and I'll be
your moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab roots and brought to you by 10x
genomics to learn more about our sponsor
please visit www.dent.umich.edu/license
a question box and click send if you
have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation click on the support tab
found at the top-right of the
presentation window or report your
problems by clicking on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen this presentation is
educational and best offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credit I now present today's
speaker dr. William J Greenleaf
associate professor the department of
genetics at Stanford University for a
complete biography on our speaker please
visit the biography tab at the top of
your screen dr. greenly you may now
begin your presentation all right well
thank you very much for for having me
here and indeed I will be talking about
that very long title which I've
shortened in this presentation to
multi-omics integration and I'd like to
just point out my various conflicts of
interest so moving on here to our first
slide which I think a lot of people
presumably have seen before is the
classic depiction of what Conrad
Washington in 1957 conceptualized as
what differentiation might look like a
ball rolling down this sort of beautiful
landscape with various hills and every
time the sort of the cell is a cell as
it differentiates from a multipotent
to
a more fully differentiated state sort
of hits one of these decision points it
needs to decide if it's going to the
left to the right and becoming a t cell
or a B cell or progenitor to those sorts
of cells and then eventually landing
down here at the bottom of you know
using up some of its energy in this
landscape landing at the bottom of this
phenotypic landscape in sort of a fully
differentiated State so this has been
sort of an enlightening analogy for how
cells maintain their state and and and
transition across different states but
perhaps fewer people have seen the
second slide which was actually the next
figure in his book where we go
underneath that landscape and try and
understand what sets this landscape of
differentiation what pulls the ball into
different developmental fates and he
conceptualized these guy wires that are
pulling down on this sort of trampoline
pulling the cell into different sort of
lineages which of course are things like
transcription factors that's what these
guy wires are attached to and of course
they can be coupled and things like this
and this is much more sort of
mechanistic understanding of what must
be driving cell state changes and I
think my lab and and many are interested
in trying to both define what it means
to transition epigenetically across
different states but also try and get at
the molecular drivers of these
differentiation states and ideally the
molecular drivers as well of disease
states and just to remind everyone very
high level more or less every cell in
your body has the same genome but
obviously brain cells and lung cells and
blood cells behave very differently and
much of that is encoded in this
landscape of chromatin I be identifying
which elements in in the genome are open
and accessible to the machinery of
transcription and which are shut down
and of course different regulatory
elements being on drives different
dreams gene expression programs which
then brings about different phenotypes
and of course much of this is driven by
the differential binding of
specific sequence dependent binding
proteins transcription factors and so
one relatively productive way to sort of
look at how regulation is occurring at
the level of genome is to make this
approximation where regions that are
open that is to say they can be bound by
transcription factors they're open to
the machinery of transcription or have
the potential to be regulatory that is
to say on and if they are inaccessible
then very likely they are not regulatory
because they cannot be bound by
transcription factors another machinery
of transcription and so again just to
sort of highlight this again that you
can imagine multiple different cell
types to generate different gene
expression programs here's two different
cells that then this is the promoter of
that and you can imagine these enhancers
that are differentially bound by
specific transcription factors that then
drive this gene expression and really
what we're excited to try and understand
is how those that the regulatory
landscape changes and so this in some
sense the lot of the gene expression
starts sorry this is sort of the why of
the gene expression what when it comes
to trying to understand regulation at
the level of individual cells okay sorry
so the question is maybe is are there
ways to try and profile transcription
factor binding sites and their
interactions with the chromatin
genome-wide and my lab in collaboration
with Howard Chang and driven for by
Jason Wynn rostro and others dilip this
assay of transpose a is accessible
chromatin or a taxi which is a method
for profiling the maybe one or two
percent of the genome that's actually
accessible to the binding of
transcription factors in any specific
cell type of interest in this is a
method that's relatively straightforward
you basically isolate nuclei with more
or less chrome intact chromatin which
looks like this you add this tm5
transposes which actually uses a
cut-and-paste
to insert sequencing adapters directly
into DNA that's accessible and so in a
single step you basically are marking
the regions of the genome that have that
have accessibility by adding a a
sequencing adapter and then you can
isolate these fragments which now are
amplify Abul and then use Hydra put
sequencing to sequence these map them
back to the genome and you get a
collection of reads at regions of
accessibility so this is a relatively
straightforward assay that has been
applied at least in bulk to a large
number of different systems so okay
sorry so again what does this look like
well at in cell type one in blue we
would expect enhancers to have increased
accessibility and therefore increased
reads coming from the transposition
reaction whereas in cell type two we
might expect a decrease in that
accessibility which also is associated
with a lower level of gene expression
okay so we can also ask for example
which sequences within that accessible
element are for example enriched across
the accessible elements of cell type 1
and then we can get from the enrichment
of different cameras within these
accessible elements we can get motifs
which then we can try and Link through
databases to specific transcription
factors which like to bind those motifs
so we get some information about well
putative regulatory elements are
accessible but also which putative
regulatory transcription factors might
be binding those those elements and we
can also on the right here see that we
can often footprint these transcription
factors that is to say when the
transcription factor is bound to that
DNA you get a protection of that DNA at
that locus and the transpose is unable
to insert sequencing adapters into that
those 10 or 20 base pairs and
so you get sort of the echo of the
binding of that transcription factor
okay so we uh we wanted to apply this
method I at the single cell level is
method for looking at chromatin
accessibility to try and both define a
normal differentiation in a sort of a
classic system in this case it's going
to be hematopoiesis but also to try and
understand abnormal leukemic development
and to try and understand this we
actually chose this special kind of
leukemia an acute leukemia of
ambiguously lineage so there are you can
get leukemias that look much like they
are coming from a mile any edge you can
get leukemias that look like they're
coming from the lymphoid lineage but you
can also get a leukemias that actually
look like they are kind of either
individual cells that come from myeloid
and lymphoid lineage or cell subsets
that come from lymphoid and cell subsets
that come from myeloid all in the same
leukemia and just to give you a little
this desert what people call mix between
the type acute leukemias and so these em
pals again have multiple sort of lineage
profiles and when you look this is sort
of the classic hierarchy of
hematopoietic development starting from
hematopoietic stem cells and moving down
into CC d3 for bone marrow progenitors
which are again multipotent but sort of
lineage committed and then you get
further down this tree into fully
lineage committed cells like T regs in
cd4 and cd8 t-cells but you can see in
this M pal flow cytometry on the right
that we have one axis of c3 which is a
lymph lymphoid marker and MPO which is a
myeloid marker and you can see
populations of cells that exist both in
this lymphoid sorry a population of
cells that looks very lymphoid like and
another population that looks very
myeloid like that are both present
simultaneously in this patient and in
another patient for example we have
populations of cells
look like that you have both markers for
lymphoid and myeloid so this is really
interesting because and then we also
have here's another example of a
population of cells that looks very
lymphoid like and also another
population that looks both lymphoid and
myeloid like this is really interesting
because there's really good evidence
that the genetics of these
subpopulations is basically the same all
of these cells have the same genetic
abnormality but they have very different
sort of phenotypic a sort of outcomes
and so this screams for some sort of
epigenetic root cause for why this might
be happening so we wanted to use
single-cell data to better characterize
these diverse mpow phenotypes okay so to
try and understand how we might do that
we want to develop an analytical
framework that's going to identify
disease profiles in the this normal in
the normal context and so the first
thing we have to do is try and
understand a reference map for what
healthy blood development looks like at
the level of open chromatin landscapes
and then we can project these multi
phenotypic issues the linked leukemias
these disease cells into this healthy
reference map both to try and understand
what the the closest healthy cell for
these em pals are that is to say what
regulatory program is the closest normal
but also then to regress out that normal
program and ask what sort of regulatory
program is running on top of that normal
differentiation program that is specific
to these disease cells okay so that's
the strategy first we'll try and create
this reference map of healthy blood
development and we did this using a
multi ohmic approach so this is a multi
ohmic droplet uh based single cell
profiling of healthy blood development
we carried out sort of two different
assays one is this site seek assay which
allows for the quantification of protein
surface markers on individual cells by
using DNA linked antibodies so you have
a bunch of different antibodies that
each have a specific DNA sequence
associated with them and that allows you
to quantify these
surface markers just by doing sequencing
and then we simultaneously in those
cells also generate gene expression data
using single-cell RNA so you could poly
a tail and then separately but with the
same sample we generate single cell
attack seek on the 10x platform as well
and again this gives genome-wide
chromatin accessibility information and
allows us to try and infer but both
transcription factor activity levels but
also actually we can try and infer gene
expression from chromatin accessibility
nearby the promoter of genes as well so
now we have these two sort of different
distinct single cell data sets one of
which has protein and RNA information
and another which has chromatin
information okay so now we're projecting
these normal Hamato poetic cells and
Mort and differentiated cells as well
into a sort of a down a d-dimensional
Eyes landscape using you map which is
sort of a classic way of taking a very
large matrix that has many dimensions
and trying to project it into
two-dimensional space so that people
could try and conceptualize this and now
on the left we have that that projection
generated solely from the RNA seek data
from on the order of 35,000 cells and on
the right we have that same that
projection generated solely from this
single cell a taxi data and you can see
immediately that even though these these
datasets are entirely distinct generated
that you know one is chromatin and one
is a RNA they really pull out the same
clusters and we've colored the clusters
based on sort of expert annotations but
you can see up in the in the sort of top
so the teal I guess a sort of green
issue the hematopoietic stem cells which
can differentiate down into an erisa
and then you can see in both of these
landscapes that the B cells are at the
end of an extensive sort of
a collection of different sort of
clusters of cells that walk down the
differentiation all the way to to be
cells you can see the monocytes down
here at the purple at the bottom the
neutrophils actually turn out to be a
little bit easier to see in the RNA seek
and then you see a similar collection of
fully differentiated cells as well so
these are very sort of complimentary
datasets one is asking about what the
regulatory landscape looks like for the
open chromatin landscape looks like for
these different cell types and the other
is sort of the output of that sort of
physical state that is to say the RNA
expression levels okay and so of course
we can dive in now and ask about for
these different clusters what does the
open chromatin landscape look like for
each individual cell and now around city
14 locus you can see the amount of
product stem cell cmp GMP and the
monocyte populations each dot here so
each row is an individual cell in each
dot is a different read at that locus we
are observing from the the ataxic data
and then for the same clusters we can
look at the average single cell RNA
expression and see that as the
accessibility especially around the cd14
gene body and part of the promoter goes
up we see increase gene expression as
well and actually there's lots of
accessibility opening up down there in
the monocyte dimension and then we also
have the surface marker information
derived from the ADT's so these are
again these antibody linked DNA s oh and
so this is the C 14 surface marker gene
expressed wrong correspondence between
the RNA and the the protein there okay
so that's something that shows this
strong agreement across surface markers
expression and even inferred expression
actually across blood development so
what we can do is now what we're doing
is looking here at surface markers
specifically and so you can see here is
to see at the top row we're looking at
in the RNA seek manifold we're looking
at surface marker a signal from the a
BTS at C D 3 C 14 C 219 and cd8 a and
then comparing that to the gene
expression of those genes from the RNA
seek data and you can see very strong
correspondence between C D 3 and 314 cv
19 is actually very still pretty hard to
see there's a lot of dropout proceeding
19 there's not a lot of reads quite
often but it's very very clear on that
with the surface markers and there's and
once you see the surface markers you
need to kind of see the gene expression
as well and then cd8 a down there in the
cd8 t-cells and now we can also show the
projection just to remind you the single
cell ataxic manifold and now on the left
and the lower row of of these is is is
now what we're inferring to be the gene
expression based on the chromatin
landscape nearby the promoter whether
it's especially open or closed actually
using regulatory elements that are
especially correlated with promoter
accessibility so you can see this
inferred gene activity is actually
recapitulating a lot of what we observe
in the expression space as well sort of
pan differentiated cells are high for c
3 c 14 down there near monocytes seen in
CD 19 again a little hard to see but
moving down the B cell differentiation
trajectory and again cd8 a but but
remember that lower row is a different
manifold generated solely from the
single cell ataxic data compared to the
RNA c okay so now we have these
reference maps for a healthy blood
development all we can do is take the m
pals these disease cells and try and
project them now onto that this healthy
reference map sort of using using the
healthy map as sort of a guide and that
subspace that
it generates as the space that we're
going to force these disease cells to
project into and so again here on the
Left we have were this is a the manifold
that we that we had we're going to
project now cells into this manifold and
just to make sure that this all makes
sense if we project a taxi examples into
this manifold they all that have been
previously sorted or previously
identified they all project into the
right locations as do actual single cell
data sets that were actually generated
on an entirely different platforms so
this makes us confident that what we're
observing this this this projection
manifold that we're forcing these cells
to live and make sense when we project
cells into them they they live in the
location that's closest to the to where
the normal should be okay so again we're
going to start with these five M pal
patients from both uncoated unsorted
bone marrow aspirates as well as
peripheral blood we're going to project
these cells into these different
landscapes and now we've sort of colored
these a little more roughly and we'll
talk about what those colorings are
effectively now what we're doing here on
the left
we're taking this mpow one we're taking
the blasts from this leukemic patient
projecting the cells into that
single-cell RNA landscape and you can
see that they're landing actually both
in myeloid and you can see the
classifications on the right with road
like lymphoid light my load like
progenitor like and then also healthy
like because of course there are blasts
in this population as well as normal
blood cells you can see that for this
patient for example there are black
there are their myeloid like cells that
project all the way down near monocytes
as well as some progenitor like cells
that project relatively close to the
hematopoietic stem cell compartment and
this is true both in the RNA seek
projections as well as the attack seek
productions and you can see for both of
those they we end up with relatively
similar
fractions of these different cells and
if I move on to the next patient this
patient has far more healthy cells but
you can see also that oops that in
comparison to this patient which has a
fair number of cells projecting down the
erythroid like development trajectory
this patient has really no erythroid
life cells most of them end up looking
very myeloid like and there are some
lymphoid like cells as well so we get a
very fine-grain molecular phenotyping
both from the rna-seq and attack seek
given given this sort of projection
strategy into sort of normal development
okay so now we have the we've projected
these abnormal cells to their closest
healthy cell what we now want to do is
regress out the normal signal and ask
what the residual is that is to say what
is the abnormal gene expression or
regulatory open chromatin landscape look
like in these in these M pals and so to
do that again what we're going to do is
project them into this normal landscape
we get our diseased cells we get the
closest normal we effectively subtract
one from the other
in these subgroups of lymphoid like
myeloid like or progenitor like and then
we're going to get specific dizzy
ideally disease specific elements okay
so what does that look like so there's a
lot to look at in this slide but now
what we're projecting what we're showing
here is the differential RNA seek
compared to the nearest normal cells so
these are the differentials these are
the sort of disease specific gene
expression and this is ordered in a very
specific way across the top you can see
the different colors are different
patients so we have three subpopulations
right these are the cells that are most
like lymphoid
progenitor alike or myeloid like within
that first patient that's the whole
first three column and then the next
sort of set of columns is patient two
and then patient three and four and five
etc and you can see very
obviously there's a lot of within
patient variability in these gene
expression profiles so quite often the
regulatory program is relatively unique
to patients but it's actually shared
across the cells that project into
different parts of the hematopoietic
hierarchy that is to say even if you
project you look very myeloid like the
the dysfunctional regulatory sort of
gene expression programs are very
similar to your sort of fellow blasts
that that ended up projecting into the
lymphoid like a area and you can see
that is that it's also true in this
differential attack seek so again lots
of within patient if you compare
patients the dysfunction tends to be
there's a lot of elements that are
private to the patient but they're
shared across the possible a shion's of
cells within that patient but if you
look at the these classes up here these
tend to be the regulatory elements on
the right and the gene expression the
genes on the left that are especially
shared across all individuals so these
are the sites that are enriched and so
can we try and identify for example
transcription factor binding sites that
are enriched in these conserved and
differentially accessible regions so if
we just look at the gene at the motif
enrichments for these attack seek Peaks
that tend to be sort of more or less
uniformly differential when compared to
sort of normal hematopoiesis we see that
especially in cluster 4 and 10 this
runks one motif shown here is sort of
especially enriched which makes us think
that perhaps runks one may be driving
some of these differential accessibility
so can we further maybe identify which
specific genes might be being driven by
runks one so one way to do that is to
try and link attack seek Peaks - that is
to say chromatin accessibility Peaks two
genes within that are within 250 Kb
and we can do that and with these peek
to gene linkages then we can ask which
transcription factors which are present
in those accessibility Peaks are
potentially regulating which genes so
then we can go from try and identify
genes that are especially regulated by
specific motifs which we think then are
being bound by transcription factors
okay so we're going to try and link
these attacks seek Peaks two genes
within 250 KB so the way this works is
that we ask whether or not the
accessibility in cell type 1 an enhancer
1 is correlated with the gene expression
of the the promoter that's nearby and
then if for example that enhancer is or
a putative enhancer is less accessible
in cell type 2 we get less gene
expression at the promoter so we
basically look for correlations between
a taxi peaks and the gene expression of
nearby promoters right and then if we
see a strong correlation we at least
have some support for the possibility
that enhancer is linked to that gene
there it is okay so here's how we do
that we take the attack seek data we
take this single so RNA seek data we
actually align the two subspaces using a
Sarat Cora canonical correlation
analysis so now we have one manifold
where we use the predicted gene
expression from the chromatin landscape
to correlate that sort of gene
expression score with the nearest single
cell RNA seek data and so we've sort of
merged these two manifolds and this
actually works pretty well if you
project the these two things into the
same manifold here's sort of the the
joint manifold and then what we're going
to do is then find the nearest neighbors
in this Cora canonical correlation space
here for example is where the matched
single-cell RNA seek project into the
attack seek space and again much
you can see that the colors are more or
less where they should be based on what
we had previously annotated and now
because we have this sort of joint
manifold we can do this correlation
analysis and here are the peak to gene
linkages that have passed a sort of
false discovery threshold and so here on
the top sort of half of these matrix
this matrix you can see all the attacks
seek Peaks and RNA seek genes that have
been linked in that in the sort of a
healthy hierarchy and then in the Empire
key and then the shared and you can see
obviously by eye they look very very
correlated because in some sense we've
chosen the accessible elements that are
highly correlated with their local gene
and so now we have these this set of
potential peaked gene linkages which we
hope is enriched for true regulatory
elements and the genes that they
regulate and now we're going to try and
identify which genes have transcription
factors that we care about so we're
going to ask for example for this runks
one motif can we identify Peaks that are
especially enriched for rungs one and
then identified the genes that are
linked to those Peaks and if we do that
we can sort of come up with two
different scores one is how many times
those motifs
end up nearby that gene in a linked peak
and that's sort of the vertical axis and
then the horizontal axis is how often
how many of the MPL subpopulations is
that sort of true for we can see that
c69 locus stands out especially and if
we go and look at the CD 69 locus it
really has a really interesting signal
and if you can look on the upper right
there
we're now plotting the chromatin
accessibility plot at the CD 69 locus
and you can see the gene at the bottom
there that's sort of to orient you at
where where CTD 9 is and the way we're
plotting this is that again each sort of
3/4 mpow one are all the green from a
single patient and then those three
different tracks are the different
subpopulations from that patient and now
what we're showing is in
gray it's the expected normal
accessibility landscape and in red is
the abnormal component of that landscape
the accessibility over and above what
one would have expected from sort of
normal differentiation and you can see
there's tons of accessibility
differential actually in all of these
patients in more or less all of the
subsets and if we we can then layer on
gene expression in these sub sets as
well and you can see around CD 69
there's significantly more accessibility
and there's also significantly more gene
expression almost universally across all
of these different sub compartments in
all of these patients and if we just
look at rungs one chip seek and are
called peaked gene linkages as well as
the specific peek to gene linkages that
were identified in CRISPR a in jerk ad
cells there's really good concordance
here suggesting that really runks one is
highly enriched for these differential
accessible sites there's a strong
differential gene expression and we
would we would think that it's likely
that it's being driven by rungs one
specifically at this locus ICU 16 is
especially interesting because it's an
it's a marker for proliferation and
other things so this is just sort of an
example of how one can use this linked
single cell data to do very fine grained
analysis of potential regulatory
dynamics at specific loci in in human
disease states so we've developed an
analytical framework to map abnormal
cells into this healthy reference state
we've used this identif this information
to deconstruct disease profiles in the
heterogeneous disease and then find
conserved as well as patient specific
disease sort of molecular signatures and
we can use this multi-omics single held
data to link putative transcription
factors to their specific target disease
genes as well so I just want to point
out of course all the people who
actually did the work this is the most
important
slide so I will specifically call out
Jason Bourne rostro who developed a taxi
kin some of the initial implementations
of the single cell attacks week along
with Beijing Lu in my lab much of the m
hal work was done by jeff Karanja
this is a graduate student in my lab as
well as Lisa McGinnis and sandy Clem who
are both postdocs and much of this was
in collaboration with Howard Chang as
well as Ravi machete and I'm excited to
take questions and answers hopefully
I'll be able to give some answers so
thank you again
Thank You dr. greenly for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar we have dr. sandy Clem here with
us available to answer your questions
dr. Clem is a postdoctoral researcher in
dr. Greenleaf lab at Stanford University
and one of the researchers involved in
this study prior to joining the
Greenleaf lab dr. Clem received his PhD
in electrical engineering and computer
science from MIT and his Master of
Philosophy in engineering from the
University of Cambridge okay let's get
started if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screens will answer as
many questions as we have time for all
right our first question is is an open
chromatin region an enhancer or can it
be a repressor
I would think it's a good question
in our experience one can have
accessibility both in enhancers and in
repressor regions provide that there's
transcription factors that bind there
and so if there is transcription factor
binding and particularly nucleosome
exclusion one would expect to find
accessibility now of course if you have
closed chromatin binding of polycomb or
other kinds of repressive factors that
leads to a chromatin state that is not
accessible and so in those cases on they
would not see a signal of in the attack
seek assay
you
great thank you all right next question
if an open chromatin region is located
on the exon region what is its function
well this is another really good
question and one that has also puzzled
us as well
obviously these regions are very active
and so they are intrinsically accessible
in the census it's a transcribed gene
and then polymerase will be extending
down the gene body and as a consequence
working its way around nucleosomes
nucleosomes are not entirely excluded
within gene bodies of course but they do
interact with the polymerase but the
actual function and in particular the
rise of Peaks or aggregation of
accessible regions within exons is
something that's not well explored
thank you all right this is a two-part
question how many blood of marrow
how many blood marrow peripheral blood
samples does a thirty five thousand
eight hundred eighty two FC RNA seek /
35 zero hundred zero
sorry 35 thousand 38 cells FCAT sec new
maps represent and are they all overlaid
or from a single sample
okay so I there are two broad categories
of samples that we've used here there
are healthy samples which will outlined
is the the baseline from which we look
at the mixed phenotype of Cuba Chema's
which is the other sample category in
the housey category each of the
different compartments is measured with
two different samples so we have two
patient samples different patients that
are cd34 positive phone marijuana
nuclear cells there's then the whole
class of bone marrow mono supranuclear
cells that have not been selected as c34
positives or two of those samples and
then there are of course peripheral
blood mononuclear cells and in that case
because this is a starting port for us
for pilot analysis we have about four to
five different patients all of those are
represented in the you map space that is
shown that all of the cells from all of
those different samples are represented
in the healthy u maps for the mixed
phenotype buku leukemias we have
duplicates for each of the six sample
there are five patients and one of those
patients is a relapse so it's taken
about a year after the first sample so
there are six patients 12 total samples
you
thank you all right this one is also a
three-part question so first is how is
the data prepared and normalize of two
different platforms
was the data normalized and prepared
okay so we because we wanted to directly
compare chromatin accessibility and the
transcriptional maps and we wanted to
use rather similar approaches to do this
and so as one may be familiar with Jason
terzi's lab has introduced a way of
looking at chromatin accessibility data
using latent semantic indexing which
essentially involves binarize accessible
regions within the genome transforming
those into a lower dimensional space and
through a kind of PCA it's actually an
SVD and then in that lower dimensional
space then projecting into u maps we
actually were able to take a very
similar approach with respect to the
transcriptional data and use a similar
framework in order to understand it on
on similar terms this is a there are of
course a variety of ways of looking at
transcriptional data since this has been
available for quite some time and so
this is somewhat different than the
literature standards for example those
the normalization used in in Sarat and
this feeds into the fact that we're
trying to construct projected view maps
and as a consequence we wanted to
protect these data set contains very
similar pipeline hope that addresses the
question the preprint goes into detail
precisely how those normalizations are
done but they are done in a similar way
that broadly speaking is modeled on the
straight labs approach to looking at
crouched accessibility days
now along with that question this user
asked was that was the data scaled and
was their sample missing from one type
data if so how was it handled
is it data-scale so on the attacks each
side the data is binarized and most of
the analysis on the rnase side is done
in logarithmic specs and so if that's a
scaling that's being asked those are the
two for their baseline scaling in terms
of missing data I'm not entirely sure
the question here is on the you map's
the calls of cell types and the
clustering are all performed
independently it's not until the later
stage of analysis that will describe
where we actually seek to integrate
those manifolds but the two data sets
are are kept separately and we're able
to identify all cell types independently
in the two different the two different
data types
you
thank you okay next question where the
single-cell RNA and single-cell attack
data generated with the same batch of
nuclei
though that's different for the healthy
end for the mixed phenotype cue leukemia
for the healthy samples we used data
sets that were from all different
patients with with the exception of the
bone marrow mononuclear cells which were
actually from the same patient if the
NICS phenotype to leukemia is were from
the same batch of nuclei and I want to
be clear about what we're talking about
obviously it's not the same nucleus it's
the same sample and so we split samples
from the patient aliquot into certain
nuclei that would be processed for
attack and a set of whole cell that
would be processed for the RNA
sequencing and that's because those
samples are very precious of course very
rare disease and in some cases we only
had a single aliquot of each
great thank you okay can you tell me
what the difference between chromatin
accessibility gene activity scores and
TS activity
yes that is so when you look at a gene
activity score this is from coal trap
Noel's lab and the Cicero package which
looks at distal and proximal
accessibility correlations to predict
the activity level of a neighboring
locus and that is the basis for the
framework for integrating RNAi attack
manifold first the accessibility
manifolds are converted into a gene
activity score space and then those
those activity scores are interpreted as
gene expression levels allowing us to
directly integrate the transcriptional
and epigenetic manifolds I and there's
of course manuscripts on that out of the
Trotman lab the TF I activity or score
is simply an enrichment within
differential Peaks
thank you we are getting so many great
questions okay the question let's see
following the enhancer and repressor
questions how often do you see
negatively correlated enhancer and gene
expression
negatively correlated enhancers and a
gene expression
something that we have examined directly
here it is certainly true that many
accessible regions many reputed
regulatory regions are not correlated
with gene expression levels so when you
can have changes in gene expression
levels in a perfectly constant chromatin
accessibility landscape but the negative
interactions is not something that we've
specifically examined
you
okay what method worked best for
identifying the differentially expressed
genes between normal and leukemia cells
well this is the core part of the
analysis is something that we have spent
some time considering and if you have a
cell type that is sort of reasonably
distinct from other cell types and the
differential changes that you're looking
at are only a very small part of that
cellular landscape the African etic
landscape in that case you know
historically the ways to approach those
questions is perhaps to physically
isolate those cells and make direct
comparisons to known cell types and or
their counterparts in the case of
cancers however the actual mutational
changes which give rise to epigenetic
changes distort the developmental
trajectories of those cells and as a
consequence they don't live in a normal
canonical space a well-defined self-id
they're actually distributed in our
analysis mostly across the entire UNC 34
compartment early developmental
compartment of bone marrow and so as a
consequence when you're looking at cells
like this we found that the most natural
way of determining what the leukemia
specific cancer program is that's
running within these cells is to take
each individual mixed phenotype of Q
leukemia and then in a lower dimensional
space which would be this latent
semantic indexing reduced dimensionality
space from the singular value
decomposition in that space and I want
to particularly distinguish that from
the u map extremely low dimensional
space but in that intermediate
dimensional space one finds a nearest
neighbor to each cell and actually in
our case we're finding a collection of
nearest neighbors and we use those
nearest neighbors then to build up for
each pound a particular compartment a
cohort of normal cells that are nearby
to that and those cells actually live in
different
on CD 34 subtypes and so some of these
might be very early lymphoid progenitors
and some of them may actually be later
progenitor cells then we take each of
those cells that have at least one
Mexican type acute leukemia
nearest-neighbor and simply look at the
log to a different log full change
between those healthy normals and the
mixed phenotype acute leukemia cells
that are in a particular matter poetic
compartment and then the rest of the
analysis really is fairly canonical
differential analysis between those two
subpopulations similar to if you had
physically isolated or separated to
stink two cell types so that the
challenge and it's go specifically to
the question about what is the most
natural way of looking at differential
changes and the challenge is to identify
what is the closest normal and that
allows us to look at differentials and
in that differential our interpretation
is whatever is differential is the
leukemic epigenetic program
great thank you how many samples from
both single-cell attack and single-cell
RNA does it need to assign subspace
I not sure that I entirely understand a
question can you repeat it I think it
said bulk
we don't use any bulk data in analysis
but can you reread the question sure
it says how many samples from both
single-cell attack and single-cell RNA
does it need to assign subspace
oh sorry I misheard the question and so
how many do you need to assign the
subspace we haven't changed sampled our
data and obviously this very much
depends both on the type of sub states
that one wants to deconvolve
and it also depends on the analysis
that's being done let's look at those
two questions separately in terms of the
cd34 positive compartment five to ten
thousand cells robustly on deep involves
the department one could probably manage
to get a fairly accurate map with a few
thousand cells in fact in Prior work
we've used a lower throughput platforms
microfluidic platforms to do single cell
a taxi and those have in the thousands
of cells and we were able to produce
similar but very sparsely sampled
chromatin accessibility maps so on the
low end let's say a few thousand cells
and then on the high end you know five
to ten in our case we have nearly twenty
thousand cells in the bone marrow and
see thirty four compartments if you're
looking at a much less complex set of
cell types such as such as peripheral
blood mononuclear cells there you've
only need really a few hundred to
thousands of cells to get a very clear
picture of the broad categories of T
cells B cells and monocytes
to answer the second part of the
question which is very much depends on
the analysis and building a you map or a
categorization of the different types
it requires perhaps fewer numbers of
cells depending on the type of
downstream analysis that you want to do
in our case the differential analysis
it's rather important to have a very
robustly sampled landscape because we're
asking for nearest neighbors we really
want the cell that would have been the
state of our mix pow2 leukemia had it
not acquired certain mutations and taken
an epigenetic trajectory off of normal
mat poiesis and so in that case it's
very important that the nearest neighbor
is really close by and epigenetic space
also when we look in the final bit of
analysis at looking at integrating the
two manifold from chromatin
accessibility transcriptional data there
the underlying assumption is that we can
assign the transcriptional state of one
cell to the chromatin state of another
cell that are different cells there
sample of course and measured
differently and so in order for that
assumption to be broadly accurate it's
very important that there is a
neighboring cell again that would have
had that transcriptome or that epigenome
had we been able to observe it in the
same cell and so in those cases it needs
to be very very richly sampled a precise
number of how many you need very much
depends on complexity of the types of
cells on the one is trying to
disambiguate
thank you did you include the surface
protein expression and the list of
markers used to cluster cells in the
healthy map
some of them are used some of the
canonical ones I see 14 for example and
we use cd8 and c4 in order to
distinguish different subtypes so in
that case yes but not all of them and of
course the chromatin accessibility site
where these are through this analysis
was performed separately we're looking
at very different marks some of them are
not even proximal enhancers so in many
cases we're looking at distal enhancers
that are known to have differential
accessibility across them out of rhesus
great thank you it looks like we have
time for a few more how does binarize
incoming and come into place and how do
you determine if a transcription factor
is on or off
so on the chromatin accessibility side
all of the data is binarized and that is
a pretty mild data transformation on
with very little information lost
because in any given cell at any
particular locus one can only observe
two to four different copies in that
cell - if it's in g1 one is in a
replicated state or q2 then you can have
up to four copies but and so those could
be of interest to look at in a
quantitative graded scale and student
and nothing to not fight arise the
challenges with a lot of this data is
that it can be quite noisy because of
mapping issues spurious mapping issues
and the the cost of non non binarized
computational approaches to looking at
that is often over weighed by the noise
reduction benefit that you get on being
a binarized context so the you map and
the clustering is all done on binarized
chromatin accessibility and i the second
part of the question that I think that I
may have forgotten can you repeat the
question
sure of course it says how do you
determine if a transcription factor is
on or off oh that's a great question so
previously if you followed some of the
work that's come out of will Greenleaf's
lab they've produced a analytic
framework which has come under the name
of chrome bar and the basic analysis
that this uses it takes a transcription
factor view of chromatin accessibility
and in single cells this lens can be
particularly informative because of the
sparsity of reads so in any particular
locus there are very few reads to
observe but you can imagine asking a
question for a particular transcription
factor if one looked at all of the
places where a putative levi's and one
can get a rough estimate of this based
on either chip seek data or motif
matching I and then ask the question
across all those potential binding sites
what is the difference in accessibility
in that cell then you can get a picture
of the activity of that transcription
factor so one can't conclusively say
whether the transcription factor is on
or transcribe or active but you can't
look at it's a binding motif and ask
whether those tend to be accessible the
underlying intuition is that if the
transcription factor is bound then it
will be accessible in that region and if
it's not expressed at all the regions
where it may have positively bound will
be less accessible this isn't always
true it's not a universal rule but over
the last couple of years in developing
this particular frame it tends to be
quite informative and if it were true
that a transcription factor was not
expressed and yet all of its sites are
accessible that would argue that the
transcription factor doesn't have any
broad
value and changing accessibility of
course a transcription factor can have
profound consequences in the genome at a
very small number of low sites
developmental programs are replete with
example of this type but in general one
can say something just looking at
chromatin accessibility differential
changes by looking at the footprint of
transcription factors and resolving what
is the change in accessibility in a
transcription factor by transcription
factor way
thank you again doctor Greenleaf and dr.
Clem for your time today if you have any
final comments for our audience before I
let you go
oh well thank you for for having us on
it's great to describe some of the work
that's going on there were of course
very excited to look at some these
clinical samples and use of the new
technologies that are available to kind
of analysis
great thank you again we would also like
to thank lab roots and our sponsor 10x
genomics for underwriting today's
educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us and for their
questions any questions we did not have
time for today and those submitted
during the on-demand period will be
addressed by the speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration this webcast can be viewed
on-demand lab routes will alert you via
email when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye